the expanded dune books written by Brian
Herbert and Kevin J Anderson contain an
alternate timeline with dates and
accounts of history contradicting those
found in the dune encyclopedia some
unknown amount of time before the
formation of the Empire the wet planet
Arrakis was infected with the sand trout
which trapped the planet's moisture
within its core desert affine the planet
during the old Empire the first Kaja
ters were created when some revered
scientists and philosophers transferred
their brains into preservation canisters
which allowed them to go on and develop
their more advanced interpretations of
the nature of reality and the universe
this was around 2200 BG sometime after
this a schism occurred within the Buddha
Islamic religion one of the groups
became the Zen scheitz and the other
became a Zen Sunnis who would later
inhabit Arrakis and evolved into the
Fremen 800 years later in 1381 B G as in
Sunni breakaway from male myth who was
called the third Muhammad in 1287 B G
Talal ik whose original name is lost to
history and the rest of the Titans began
their conquest of the Empire one of the
original Titans named Barbarossa
programs a computer with aggression and
desire for power with his help the old
Empire crumbles before the Titans
Barbarossa was a talented technical
engineer using his unique skills he was
able to hack into the Empire's computer
network implanting of virus containing
the complicated AI subsystem that would
be key in the Titans rise to power seven
years after the rise of the Titans
Lolich dies after his death the other
Titans have themselves transformed into
a kind of cyborg known as Accomack their
brains were held in preservation
canisters similar to those found in the
first Kaja ders they had named the Titan
Agamemnon as their leader the first
rebellion against the Titans lasted from
1192
to 1183 BG on the planet wall giuse some
humans fought against titan forces and
the rebellion eventually spread to the
planet reaches and the planet Corrine
however the rebellion was ultimately
crushed by Ajax the lord of the planet
wall gist the consequences of this
rebellion would prove to be far-reaching
during the rebellion the titans ERK seas
allowed the AI network on the planet X
to reach a critical level of awareness
it became sentient and named itself
omnious in 1182 omnious makes servants
of the titans and establishes the
synchronized worlds planets fully under
the control of Thinking Machines around
400 BG the telekinetic
sorceresses of the planet Ross sec who
had later become the mini Jesuit
sisterhood first began their quiz that's
hadurok breeding program in 221 BG
Serena Butler was born 20 years prior to
the beginning of the butler II in jihad
she would be a key figure in the
struggle and eventually become a martyr
the year 201 BG marked the start of the
but Larian jihad after a revolt on the
planet Earth the Titans exterminate all
human life on the world the 10,000
systems which had not fallen victim to
the control of a I joined together to
form the League of nobles they resisted
the thinking machines the League of
nobles used nuclear weapons to destroy
all thinking machines on earth leaving
the planet itself uninhabitable
in 198 BG they moved the jihad to the
synchronized world Bella tegus but they
eventually retreat they suffer a much
greater defeat in 195 BG when the jihad
attempts to rid the planet Unruh of AI
control but failed when omnious uses
robotic ships to destroy their entire
fleet killing 500,000 people in 88 BG
omnious is finally defeated at the
Battle of Corinne though he does
broadcast a copy of himself into our
space the cult of Serena Butler which
had formed after she was killed
led the final efforts to destroy
machines on the rest of the planets of
the Imperium they completely wiped out
most machine based technology along with
most historical documents this is the
same year that Norma Silva discovered
that the spice melange could aid in
space travel and in the year one B G the
fold space shipping company changes its
name to the spacing guild monopolizing
safe faster-than-light space travel
shown company is formed and the empire
of the lion throne begins every date
afterwards is marked AG meaning after
guild in 101 nineteen AG Shaddam Kirino
is born and in 101 40 AG Leto Atreides
son of Helen reaches and Paulus Atreides
is born and 101 53 AG Vladimir Harkonnen
takes his half-brothers place as ruler
of Arrakis and in the Year 101 56 AG
shed on the 4th becomes emperor of the
Imperium after the death of Emperor L
Roode in the Year 101 71 AG the
popularity of Leto Atreides within the
Great Houses of the landsraad had grown
even more when he tries to solve the
conflict between house more itani and
house Equis which began in 101 66 AG
Leto did this the same year that the
bene Jesuits schemed to make lady
Jessica his concubine in 101 75 AG shot
on the 4th began the great spice war in
secret this war was his effort to create
a synthetic spice monopoly by destroying
the source of spice on Arrakis and
emptying the spice hordes of the Empire
in the end when the Emperor ordered the
destruction of all life on the planet
the guild whose dependence upon spice
was outmatched by none immediately
withdrew their highliners stranding the
Emperor and his
min this is the same year that Paul
Atreides was born in 101 87 AMG the feud
between house Equis and house more itani
is ended when house more Tony is
obliterated by the joint forces of House
Atreides and house Equis this happened
as the result of house more Tony
starting a war of assassins against
house Equis House Atreides moves to
Arrakis and 101 90 AG alia Atreides
becomes the regent of the empire in 102
oh nine AG after Paul Atreides walks
into the desert leaving behind his twin
children Leto and Dyneema Leto Atreides
becomes ruler of the Imperium at 102 19
AG and dies in 13 7 to 8 AG marking the
start of the great scattering the lost
ones return out of the scattering around
15200 AG and the events of heretics of
doom chapter house Doon hunters of doom
and sand worms of doon follow with no
specific dates given
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]